[Musique]
bonsoir
pour cette première émission du second
tour de l'élection présidentielle
j'ai demandé à monsieur michel barnier
député de la savoie député
l'arrondissement d'albertville de venir
me poser des questions pourquoi d'avoir
choisi c'est parce qu'il est je crois le
plus jeune député de france alors
michèle bernier quels sont vos questions
monsieur le président nous trouvons à
quelques jours du second tour et ma
première question est de savoir si vous
avez tiré quelques enseignements des
résultats du premier tour
et si au bout du compte la campagne
électorale vous a appris quelque chose
on le résultat un mot les françaises et
les français vont placer en tête des dix
candidats avec 8 million deux cent mille
voix c'est bien entendu un vote
populaire et d'ailleurs j'ai été frappé
de voir que dans certains départements
j'étais en tête malgré la tradition
politique de ces départements joue ici
serait un exemple département du nord je
suis en tête des quatre candidats et je
suis en tête dans la ville de lille et
dans la ville de roubaix donc placé en
tête par un vote populaire
ce que j'ai appris de la campagne
d'abord le fait que la jeunesse m'a
soutenu dans cette campagne je ne suis
pas toute la jeunesse elle c'est
certainement répartie ou partagés mais
une grande partie de la jeunesse m'a
soutenu c'était très important pour moi
puisque je voulais parler le langage de
l'espoir deuxième enseignement
l'importance que les françaises et les
français les plus âgés et aussi les plus
jeunes attache à la politique en faveur
de la paix et de la sécurité vous
souvenez qu'au début de la campagne on
m'avait critiqué pour cette politique
est au contraire j'ai trouvé un large
soutien pour cette politique de paix et
de sécurité
troisième enseignement la primauté
donnée par l'opinion publique aux
problèmes économiques et sociaux c'est à
dire la hausse des prix et le chômage
ce sont les premières préoccupations des
français l'heure actuelle j'ai observé
dans la campagne que certains d'entre
eux croyaient que par rapport à la
situation que nous connaissions le seul
changement pourrait être une
amélioration il se disait que l'un ou
l'autre peuvent nous apporter une
amélioration mais il ya aussi hélas la
détérioration et il y à des politiques
nous y reviendrons
dans un instant qui se traduirait par
une dégradation de la situation
économique
c'est à dire une accélération de la
hausse des prix et du chômage sur ce
problème monsieur le président même si
notre entretien bref je veux
effectivement d'abord vous parler du
chômage dans les permanences que je
tiens en savoie une personne sur quatre
une personne sur quatre cherche du
travail
je puis vous assurer que c'est une
situation très angoissante pour elle
alors ma question est de savoir comment
vous pensé passer d'un système où l'on
indemnise où l'on gère le chômage où
l'on assiste les demandeurs d'emploi un
système qui encouragera vraiment la
création de ces emplois a besoin de
préciser votre question il n'y a pas une
personne sur quatre en savoie qui
cherche mais une personne sur quatre
parmi celles qui viennent visiter le
député de la circonscription
en effet c'est un problème c'est un
problème central
vous me dites comment peut-on passer
d'une assistance aux chômeurs à une aide
à celui qui va travailler d'abord il
faut bien savoir qu'il faut apporter une
aide à celui qui est privé de ressources
et en particulier lorsqu'il ya des
licenciements pour causes économiques
par exemple une fermeture d'entreprises
ou des licenciements dans telle ou telle
branche d'activité il est évident qu'il
fallait soutenir les chômeurs c'est à
dire leur apporter les ressources
nécessaires pour pendant la période
pendant laquelle ils attendent de
retrouver un emploi
donc il n'est pas question de supprimer
l'indemnisation du chômage
par contre ce qu'il faut faire et je les
ai indiqué dans mon programme pour
l'emploi c'est de faire en sorte que ces
sommes servent davantage à aider les
demandeurs d'emploi à trouver un emploi
plutôt que de constituer une assistance
permanente à ceux qui ne trouveraient
pas ou ne chercherait pas d'emploi alors
comment faire
je crois qu'il faut une série de
dispositions nous n'allons pas entrer
dans le détail
j'illustrerai par un exemple quelquefois
vous avez des personnes auxquelles on
propose un emploi qu'elle accepterait
mais qui a une rémunération inférieure à
la rémunération qu'il touchait dans
l'emploi précédent lice dont je ne peux
pas accepter un emploi ou à des
ressources peu plus faible on peut
imaginer par exemple de conserver
pendant un certain temps
l'indemnisation du chômage ou une partie
de cette indemnisation pour compléter
les ressources du nouvel emploi du train
ailleurs et l'idée générale c'est que
nous faisons un effort de solidarité en
faveur des demandeurs d'emploi
et cet effort doit avoir comme objectif
de l'inciter d'encourager ces demandeurs
d'emploi à retrouver un travail effectif
voudrais vous dire un mot sur sur cette
question du chômage me disais tout à
l'heure qu'il ne faut pas uniquement
comparer la situation actuelle à ce qui
pourrait être de mieux mais également à
ce qui pourrait être de pire si les
propositions de l'opposition entre est
en application dans les mois prochains
c'est à dire si nous avions dit s'il
était d'abord un festival électoral
permanent
si ensuite hommage aurait massivement le
smic et certaines charges fiscales des
entreprises et certaines obligations sur
les entreprises
il n'y a pas d'entreprise en france la
mecque à vous renseigner dans vos
permanence qui embauchera à partir de
l'été prochain parce qu'ils attendront
de savoir les grandes ou petites les
moyennes
quelle sera leur situation à l'automne
et la fin de l'année
or c'est à partir du mois de juillet que
nous avons tous les jeunes qui arrivent
ils sortent de leur formation en juin
juillet et c'est la nouvelle génération
de cette année qui viendra sur le marché
du travail donc attention à une
situation dans laquelle les entreprises
en réalité ne créera pas d'emplois
justement sur les jeunes monsieur
président vous vous avez proposé au
moment des élections un peu comme par
miracle un programme pour supprimer le
chômage des jeunes en 85
pourquoi ne pas l'avoir appliqué plus
tôt ce programme nous avons commencé
beaucoup plus tôt et comme parlementaire
déroule sa vie puisque vous y avez été
associé
nous avons fait trois pactes nationaux
pour l'emploi à dire sur le plan local
toutes les autorités locales et
notamment les socioprofessionnels le
connaissent nous n'avons faire voter une
loi sur le travail à temps partiel qui a
été votée à l'automne dernier pour
permettre précédant la création de
nouveaux emplois à temps partiel
notamment pour les femmes
et nous avons depuis plusieurs années
réorganiser la formation professionnelle
avec comme objectif cette année cent
mille jeunes de plus en formation et je
voudrais que pour les jeunes la question
vous pourriez tout à l'heure à fait
clair il vaut mieux aider un jeune à
acquérir une formation que d'indemniser
un jeune qui soit en attente d'un
travail ou une formation
présent dans cette campagne du premier
tour vous le savez j'ai soutenu jacques
chirac par conviction et des millions de
français ont voté pour lui je ne suis
pas là soir pour parler au nom de mon
groupe parlementaire ou de mon mouvement
mais je crois pouvoir traduire quelques
unes des questions quelques-uns des
doutes des électeurs du rpr est l'une de
ces questions concernent la bureaucratie
concerne les charges sociales et
fiscales concernent deux crédités trop
cher concerne tout ce qui décourage et
pénalise quelquefois ceux qui veulent
prendre des risques et créer des
activités de l'emploi alors vous avez
c'est vrai libérer les prix mais vous
n'avez pas libérer les français de la
bureaucratie et aujourd'hui vous dites
il faut moins d'état qu'est ce que ça
veut dire concrètement moins d'état
c'est tout à fait concret vous avez un
candidat qui dit davantage d'état
puisqu'il veut recruter des
fonctionnaires accroître les formalités
les contrôles etc
il ya un candidat moi même qui dit moins
d'état pour libérer les forces
productives française nous avait rappelé
que nous avons supprimé les contrôles
économique qui était la plus grande
libération depuis la fin de la guerre
vous citerai deux exemples dans
l'artisanat dans l' agriculture
artisanat
nous avons beaucoup de moyens de
d'instruments dead à l'artisanat
notamment d' instruments budgétaires
mais tout ceci est compliqué je suppose
que les artisans soit en rapport avec
des administrations avec des services s
qui ne vaudrait pas mieux remplacer ces
aides par une réduction équivalente des
charges besançon tous les artisans
deuxième exemple l'agriculture nous
sommes amenés parfois aider
l'agriculture par toutes sortes de
systèmes qui sont également compliquées
notamment des aides budgétaires hauts
revenus mais il vaut mieux que ce soit
la politique des prix qui assure tout
simplement leurs revenus de
l'agriculture
donc vous voyez qu'il y à des cas
concrets par lesquels ces par des
mesures simples soit d'allègement soit
de prix qu'on peut éviter la
multiplication des interventions alors
un mot sur la paperasserie la
bureaucratie l'état à des missions à
accomplir
il a des missions de gestion de bord la
santé l'éducation la police la justice
etc
naturellement il doit les accomplir et
puis de temps en temps il a des missions
à accomplir comme par exemple à l'heure
actuelle mettons les économies d'énergie
ou l'aide à l'exportation pour le
secteur agroalimentaire et pour cela on
peut avoir d administration de mission
mais ce qui est mauvais c'est le placer
les français sous tutelle c'est à dire
d'avoir le sentiment qu'il ya au dessus
une structure qui contrôle qui décide
qui intervient dans le domaine de la vie
économique de la vie personnelle des
françaises c'est pourquoi je suis pour
moins d'état c'est à dire moins
d'interventions dans la vie économique
et sociale mais il y aura pour cela un
gros travail à faire le président
j'appartiens depuis mon engagement
personnel à la famille gaulliste
beaucoup parmi nous ont le sentiment
depuis quelques années de ne pas avoir
été de ne pas avoir été écoutés ou
simplement considérer une manière
générale une autre manière on a le
sentiment qu'il y a dans la majorité des
mal aimés et des bien aimés
comment allez-vous à l'avenir prendre en
compte nos propositions et notre
sensibilité
ce dernier j'ai dit hier devant
d'ailleurs une assistance très nombreuse
et où il y avait de vos amis j'ai dit
qu'il n'y aurait pas les bien aimés du
premier tour et les mal aimés du second
tour que c'était un grand enjeu national
qu'il fallait que tout le monde luttent
ensemble et que tous ceux qui
participeraient à ce combat qui sera à
gagner serait sur le même plan c'est à
dire qu'ils seront tous aimés de la même
manière vous me dites quelle est la
place du gaullisme où est le gaullisme
il ira d'abord excusé 7 cette formule il
est dans ma tête parce que quand on est
président la république on est par la
force des choses successeur du général
de gaulle et beaucoup des choses que
j'ai faites au cours des dernières
années j'avais fait en pensant à son
action par exemple notre défense dont
une forme d'indépendance
le fait que j'ai eu des entretiens au
plus haut niveau à tous les grands
dirigeants du monde
tout ceci c'était en réalité la
continuation de l'action du général de
gaulle et ouais son son apport à la
france ce qu'il a donné à la france ce
sont les institutions ce qui nous
distingue de nos voisins et regarder
vraiment la carte autour de nous autour
de nous nous avons le désordre politique
presque partout et ce qui nous distingue
ce sont les institutions de la vème
république
c'est cela que génère le goal à donner
est laissé à la france
et c'est pourquoi je considère que la
famille gaulliste doit avoir pas geek
non naturellement mais principalement
comme message à apporter dans la vie
politique nationale
le maintien des institutions de la vème
république qui s'ajoutent d'autres
messages socio économique
vous avez parlé à l'instant or dans le
le choix qui sourd
il est évident que les institutions de
la vème république sont en cause
ces institutions je les ai soutenus
depuis le premier jour je me souviens du
1er juin 1958 j'étais tout
lutter comme vous devez à peu près le
même âge deux ans de plus je crois et
j'ai voté en séance pour le général de
gaulle j'ai voté ensuite dans tousles
référendum constitutionnel et notamment
en 1962 où j'ai pris le risque quitter
ma famille politique pour soutenir
précisément le la proposition du général
de gaulle or il faut savoir que mon
concurrent dans cette élection a été
depuis le premier jour
l'adversaire de la vème république le
1er juin 58 quand je voter pour ils
votaient contre
en 1962 quand je votais pour l'élection
du président de la république au
suffrage universel avec la majorité des
français ils voté contre
en 1968 mai 68 quand le pouvoir vacille
est en france il se préparait à le
saisir et elle saisir des mains du chi
du général de brûler il faut se souvenir
de tout cela justement dans cette
élection monsieur le président votre
concurrent pour le jeune français que je
suis représente un peu le passé en 65
j'étais lycéen j'avais 14 ans il était
déjà candidat contre le général de
gaulle jean 74 il était encore candidat
et en soit 80 aujourd'hui est toujours
candidat je ne pense pas qu'il puisse
incarner l'espoir et l'avenir pour les
jeunes mais ces jeunes qui sont inquiets
actuellement qui ont une formidable
capacité d'enthousiasmé et de générosité
vous le savez ces jeunes ont besoin d'un
idéal et vous ne pouvez les mobiliser
que sur un idéal en leur proposant
quelque chose et je voudrais savoir ce
sera ma dernière question qui dit diane
vous conter leur proposant cet idéal
jeune leur exposé depuis le début de ma
campagne et je vous disais que le
premier enseignement j'avais tiré dans
cette campagne précisément c'était le
soutien de la jeunesse
alors cet idéal c'est quoi c'est d'abord
que la france soit un pays de pointe aux
pins puis à la traîne dans le monde mais
un pays de pointe et ce qui veut dire
qu'au point de vue de notre formation de
notre technique de notre science nous
devons apparaître comme un des pays les
plus avancés du monde ce que nous
faisons vous le savez dans beaucoup de
domaines spatial aéronautique
scientifique et ainsi de suite
deuxième objectif la qualité de la vie
les jeunes françaises et les jeunes
français sont attachés à la qualité de
la vie en france la protection de notre
nature à la protection de d'un certain
nombre d'éléments de la vie locale ou
la culture locale et il faut
naturellement répondre à cette
aspiration et puis le troisième élément
c'est l'influencé le rôle de la france
dans le monde que la france reste un
pays généreux il y a eu dans cette
campagne je voulais une exaltation de
l'égoïsme et j'ai dit moi je ne le ferai
pas je souhaite au contraire que la
france apparaisse comme un pays généreux
vis-à-vis des autres à l'intérieur
d'abord nous allons encore en france des
îlots de pauvreté nous savons très bien
dans le monde rural il encore des lots
de pauvreté il y a dans les centres
urbains ce qu'on appelle le quart monde
et je propose comme objectif pour les
sept prochaines années de faire
disparaître les derniers îlots de
pauvreté de la société française pour
qu'il n'y ait plus en france ces
catégories qui frappe en dehors si vous
voulez de de notre vie collective vis à
vis de l'extérieur c'est également
l'ouverture sur le monde
il faut d'abord que les jeunes français
connaissent le monde qui le parcours qui
le rencontrent les autres jeunes que
chaque fois qu'ils veulent le faire on
leur facilite l'accès du monde et enfin
que nous apportions notre concours au
développement du monde
une tiare monde savait très bien que les
prochaines années vont être caractérisé
par une augmentation considérable de la
population du monde par des phénomènes
de famine par des phénomènes de mauvaise
santé notamment pour les enfants dans le
monde la france doit être un pays gère
donc pour la jeunesse je leur dis soyons
api de pointe maintenant la qualité de
la vie en france et apparaissant comme
un pays fraternel à l'intérieur en
éliminant les derniers îlots de pauvreté
de la société française est comme un
pays généreux à l'extérieur en
poursuivant le dialogue et led avec les
pays en développement
voilà ce que je propose à la jeunesse
française et merci monsieur michel
barnier plus jeune député de france de
m'avoir interrogé
[Musique]